but sometimes I can't get irritated just
from the blood Shannon Doherty giving a
look inside her cancer Journey sharing
my story and being so sort of open and
honest it helped me the actress who's
currently battling stage four breast
cancer recently shared the heartbreaking
news that had spread to her brain I mean
it's changed everything in my life now
she's offering her followers a closer
look into the surgery she underwent back
in January detailing how petrified she
was to remove a tumor in her head while
admitting this is what cancer can look
like you know every day is so like
special for me
and
I think it's
I mean you just become
humble Shannon explains her attempts to
be brave but the fear was overwhelming
adding she was worried that I would come
out of surgery not me anymore any
weakness on the legs no so so
I know that that right foot is perfectly
fine the original reason why I chose to
share the diagnosis it was going to come
up anyway and it is my story Shannon
first revealed Her diagnosis in 2015 her
cancer going into remission two years
later but in 2020 she announced it had
returned so it was it was February March
of 2018.
um that I actually found out that I had
stage four cancer I wasn't vocal about
it I think that for me I needed to
I needed to process and I also wanted to
you know work and make sure that people
knew that I could work before it was
revealed and since the actress has made
it her mission to be as transparent
about her journey as possible I want to
really push for education and awareness
and raise more money and I also want
people to not
hear stage four cancer and think of the
person that you know is gray and falling
over and they can't move you get written
off so quickly even though you're still
vital and healthy and happy and wanting
to you know go out there and work so I'm
sharing in order to give hopefully a
different face
to to all of this just last week Shannon
shared another emotional post to social
media her first round of radiation
I think you realize
how many people in the world are going
through the same struggle as you and
and that you have such a larger family
than you ever thought because sort of
the cancer family is a really large
family and they're wonderful and
embracing it's just made me
appreciate people the sharing of
information the sharing of support the
sharing of love was
um healing so I you know as much as I
may struggle with social media I will
forever be thankful for it just for
those moments alone
[Music]
foreign